I am thrilled this evening we have an
excellent show for you tonight
and as always whoever has the most
whammy points will go straight on to a
double bonus but before we get to that
how is that oh wait a minute wait a
minute which camera is mine am I on
camera three or in my camera - or is it
one Stan god damn it can somebody tell
me what camera ow
sir please excuse me sir Oh three two
one and here we go hello folks and
welcome back to America's favorite game
show fill in the blanks I am your host
it truly is America's favorite I have
your host Reed Newport just like the
cigarettes yep menthols are the ones i
prefer most and the survey says ok I am
sorry sir I think you're in the wrong
studio 500 more points and that will
take us straight to it all or nothing
caught karna night I don't think that
guy can hear you I've heard about him
he's this leftover game show host from
the 80s he's wandered the studio lot for
decades since his show was canceled
let's say hello to Natasha from
Clearwater Florida
[Music]
Natacha I understand that you're an
algebra teacher how long have you been
an algebra teacher twelve years well
that's just about how long it takes
excuse me would you please leave my
audience alone hey let's get to know
deke st. Wayne all the way from Amarillo
Texas deke I understand you run a honey
farm
what's that like sticky deke you just
said our secret word
they've won
look at that it's our grand prize
looking good Connie it's a personal war
sport demise from taka homie
now this is strictly illegal in the
United States but folks if you're on
international waters let it rip I'm
sorry you know we cannot afford that we
can't afford that the cerveza
Oh tough break I don't honestly don't
know what's going three seconds on the
clock and it's just about time to find
out what's inside the box we've
eliminated both Carl and Brenda which
leaves only Carrie and I hope she
doesn't spend all of her gimme points
before it's time to pull
there's no
libertine read Newport can you hear me
someone say my name do I hear my name
somewhere I can see the outline of a
very tall girl scout for God's sake just
stop stop
well the only way to stop it Conan is to
press that brick button there's no
listen there's no red button there's no
lever
oh no red button looks like it's time to
ring that Bell this is painful and
horrid feet except your show went away a
long long time ago I'm sorry I'm sorry
but it did and this is sad it's time to
stop well maybe you're right maybe it is
time to to take a break maybe I should
pick up my things and cash in my pension
no no no no that's what he needs to do
this is good for me because I think I
really should move all the way to the
bonus room
[Applause]
Redbox the bonus round is just like the
lightning round except it's nowhere near
as fast here I go into the isolation
booth now when I hear your circle takes
the excitation
we're getting the doctor he'll be fine
so hectic so tonight from the new movie
overboard Eva Longoria
cohdon code and I think she prefers to
be called Ava Longoria Ziva it's not Ava
shut up well from the HBO series
Westworld Luke Hemsworth design Luke
Hemsworth all the way from Amarillo
Texas
he runs a honey farm all right shrill
musical guest Ben Harper Charlie
Musselwhite on the side : is that your
final answer
would you like to pull the audience take
a break we're gonna take a break we'll
be right back Jimmy take it away I'll
beg your pardon
what's the matter everything's going
just fine
you